Yeah. What changes face like, oof.
Jesus here. So I heard he's
retired, right? Connor? Yeah.
You don't buy it. Right. And then, I
don't know if you had a guess. Yeah,
he's fighting yet. Hans Mullen
camp, you know Han's from monster.
He sent me pictures of sparring with
Connor today. Oh, so Connor's training.
Yeah, I know how doing something
monsters. Yeah. It works for monster.
He's, he's training, he's got to fight.
He's probably just fucking with people,
you know.
I mean,
Connor is a master showman in terms of
like how to keep people interested in
him. And I just think he just, he got way
out of line with all this Khabib stuff,
you know? But I'd like to wait. I like the
way he takes his losses. Oh, he took it.
Well,
I like the way I like the way he goes
out there and talk smack whatever you,
when I think of like as a,
I mean like from a sports psychology
point of view, I think he's, uh, he's,
I think he's developed
there, you know? Yeah.
But I don't think the way
to get in another fight we
could be is to continue to
talk shit after he smashes.
You mean he doesn't have any reason to,
you can just talk shit like he,
he didn't just win.
He smashed and tapped you like it was,
it was only like one or two moments in
the fight where Conor was taking control
with some of the striking in the stand
up, you know, and that's another choke.
That's another misunderstood choke,
that fulcrum choke that can be got Connor
with that is a legit net crank. Yeah.
Yeah. And people that don't think
that, oh, he tapped to that.
Like you would tap to that too.
And if you didn't, you're stupid.
And people are like, yeah, because
the chin was down there right there.
Like you can, there's a lot
when you're, there's a lot of,
it generates a lot of forced Yankee down
hinge your jaw for what? Yeah, yeah.
And face apart. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That,
that's a legit, that's a legit submission.
Yeah. Especially with that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Exactly. Yeah.
Back the back of your form against the
guys back as leveraged with the cause of
that fulcrum. Yeah, that's horrific.
Very powerful. It hurts bad man.
There's a lot of those net
cranks. It just like, Oh,
you watch people and you
just go, please tap. Yeah.
There it is right there like you see with
Khabib's left arm pressing against the
back of Conner and then also yanking
on that and that is ripping his fucking
neck apartment. You never, yeah.
You until you felt one. Yeah. Yeah.
Um,
but Connor,
it's interesting that the way he's posted
up like that or just trying to get up
and he's getting cracked at the
same time. Yeah. You got to kind of,
he was already, he had already
been smashed by then too. You know,
he'd been hitting hit with so
many big punches from the top.
He takes a great shot though,
I'll tell you that. Yeah.
But it's just one of those things where
I think in order for him to really have
a real chance at getting another shot,
what he's got to do is beat somebody
big and say something that makes Khabib
considerate, you know, but not in, no,
not in the way of what he's been
doing in terms of, you know,
talking shit about him and
talking smack. I, I mean,
I think the only way it's
going to be public demand,
like he's gonna have to get to a position
where people want to see him fight.
He began to see that the result
may be different this time.
And then maybe if he could just fucking
communicate something to them, say,
you know, I respect you, you know,
all trash. Talk aside, you know,
I'd like to test myself against you
one more time. And I think I earned it.
I think that's the only way he's
going to get it. I think you're,
the only way he's going to get at is to,
to win a couple of fights,
beat some real big name guys
and then make it. So that's, uh,
something that could be, is
actually interested in. Well, okay.
So I don't know if that's the only way,
but it's the way that would be, uh,
that I would like to see.
They already offered it to Qbb keep it
could be used said fuck off. Yeah. Yeah.
That's like that path that you're
talking about. Sounds like a one,
that one that fits good for me. Yeah.
I'd like to see it that way. Yeah.
Do you think that trash talking in MMA
has gone too far or do you like it all
right? I mean, well, I think
it's entertaining. Yeah. Uh,
for some people I think it's not,
oh, here, it's, it's hard because
it's not, um, it's not
always what I want to see.
And it's not, uh, I don't know.
It's not the type of person I am,
but not everyone's going to be me.
That's not what makes the world go around.
And there's a lot of
people want to see it.
And also sometimes it does bring
some energy and some, you know,
when it's well done, it does bring some
energy and some excitement to the fight.
And to the sport and at the same time,
not every fight. What's Indian wedding?
It was really interesting and was really
excited about the UFC is that there's a
lot of fights that people want to see
that have no bearing on the title.
Right? And so there's something to that
fights that just people want to see.
And I think trash talk sometimes makes
fight that people want to see. Yeah,
for sure. Yeah, it makes sense.
Emotional makes things intense.
It's great for selling things.
It's great for selling paper views.
But the question is like,
is it good for the sport overall?
It should it be something that we
encourage. Well, how was that for,
and that's the thing is how do we decide
what's good for the sport? In what way?
Right. How do we decide, is it
good for the way the sport, uh,
do want the sport to look at as far as
martial arts and being a respectful thing
and people looking at us like that,
maybe not a,
is it good for the sport of the growth
of the sport and for more opportunities
for athletes and for our athletes
to become, uh, uh, names that,
uh, that draw attention from other people
that normally didn't know about it?
I Dunno. I Dunno either, but
yeah, so, so I dunno, I, I,
I'm torn.
I like both.
I like exactly Machida type character
that's very spiteful and bowels and never
talks trash and fights like a,
you know,
just a world champion
caliber martial artist.
And I also like the guy that talks mad
shit. I think it's funny. Yeah. Yeah,
exactly. I enjoy it. It's like,
I like press conferences for that very
reason where know guys are talking shit
to each other and they're looking over
at each other on the podium and you know,
it's funny, I'll come on there was some of
them. Yes. Some of it is hilarious. Yeah.
How about Connor?
When Jeremy Stevens slick ask them
for Pfizer Hula Fuck is that guy.
It was effective when he, when he got,
when he got up, what was like, okay,
I don't have typed in so to
everyone, so let's, yeah,
let's get them all in one
place. Right. That was great.
So I can see what everyone at one
time this be efficient. Come on.
There's comedy back when he was talking
about with red panties night. Yeah. Yeah.
That was a baby. We got there.
Caught up with Greg or fight.
He's a fucking character.
MONTCO mine isn't that weird situation
though where he really never has to fight
again. So you've got to wonder
what his motivation is. You know,
like he has $100 million.
He has a gigantic whiskey company
that proper 12 is murdering it.
That that places killing it
that that company is, they're,
they're moving into other countries now.
I mean they're killing it. He'd done,
doesn't have to do a thing ever
financially unless he wants to eat diamond
sandwiches.
He's like,
you basically could do whatever the fuck
he wants for the rest of his life and
just live off interest. But he still
likes to fight. Yeah, I think so.
Yeah. I mean that's what
brought him into the QBE fight.
He didn't have to fight Khabib, but
just, you know, how much does he want it?
I mean,
does he want it the same way a guy like
style bender wants it or a guy like
Calvin Calvin Gaslin wants it.
And also I think that, you know,
part of wanting it is different
too. Um, maybe, maybe there's,
maybe people might want things on their
terms to one certain terms of way you
get in his way. Like, like some
people be like, oh, you want it,
I want it any way I can get it.
Some people might want it and say,
well now I want it this way.
Well, he was gonna Fight Cowboy.
That was a fight that they were,
they were basically trying to make,
but it was going to have to be a
co main event. And because of that,
I think Connor was not interested in
anymore. He wanted it to be a main event,
you know? And I'm like, Jesus, like,
is that really what kept us from Connor
versus Cowboy Kenny [inaudible] versus
cowboy?
Make that a fucking main event.
Like make some malarkey title come up
with some hundred 60 pound title or some
shit. Just come on, man. Do it. I mean,
they give out these interim
titles left and right.
How about you come up with some excited
when that was going to happen? Yeah. Yeah.
I was excited to see it. Hundred 65
pound malarkey title. Just come off, man.
Conor versus cowboy for the
title. Yeah. Make a title up,
but that's what they're trying
to make it. Yeah. No, I agree.
I don't think it would hurt at all,
but apparently Dana says it makes a big
difference in the amount of paper views
here. Okay. Yeah.